As the UK gets further from the start of this pandemic,...
...business may simply cross over to the next set of challenges.
Unsustainable debt levels and vulnerabilities that COVID has exposed in supply chains...
...and systems geared to ever greater efficiency.
This Scottish manufacturer of outdoor clothing...
...was squeezed when COVID hit its supplies from Asia.
But, it expanded into making medical gowns and overhauled its logistics.
Obviously, price is quite key because we're in a very competitive market.
But, we've managed to source as much as we possibly can locally in terms of materials,...
...in terms of what we call trims, whether it's elastics...
...whether it's cuffing, these types of things.
The company would like to buy more closer to home, but the choice isn't always there.
It might also require a shift from customers like the public sector buyers...
...for whom price has tended to trump quality or provenance.
This whole situation has really highlighted how dependent we are on other countries.
I think it will be important for business, people in business...
...and people at government level to start rethinking some of that process.
Has resilience become a higher priority for business and for government?
The global supply network, people insisting on the cheapest prices...
...and going to the cheapest labor markets,...